parce que bon quand j'ai eu les gens de
chez nikon au téléphone il ya quelques
mois et qui m'ont dit la liste des spex
dans ma tête j'avais quand même envie de
répondre sérieux
[Musique]
il salue légendaire l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
vidéo
si c'est la première fois vous
atterrissez ici je m'appelle françois je
suis vidéaste c'est mon métier je fais
des vidéos et sur cette chaîne je vous
parle de montage de tournage de matos
tout ça donc si c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéresse et bien vous pouvez
envisager de cliquer sur le petit bouton
s'abonner qui se situe juste en dessous
las de cette vidéo aujourd'hui les
années on va parler d'une icône z 6 2 et
surtout surtout surtout des raisons pour
lesquelles je switche sur nikon
complètement ça y est je laisse tomber
sony pour passer entièrement sur la
gamme nikon
mais avant toute chose je tiens à
préciser que cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisé je ne suis pas payé pour
faire cette vidéo on ne m'a pas demandé
de dire quoi que ce soit mais pour que
vous ayez tous les éléments en main pour
vous faire votre propre opinion sachez
que je vais être doté un de cette gamme
nikon donc voilà c'est complètement
transparent vous pouvez mettre en doute
remettre en question pourrait vous faire
votre propre opinion comme sur toutes
les vidéos qui sont sur youtube
bien évidemment alors 2020 est-ce qu'il
faut dire vraiment 2020 il ya eu un truc
positif quand même en 2020 c'est que au
niveau technologie on a eu des sorties
dans tous les sens et surtout pour la
photo et la vidéo on a cette année tous
les constructeurs qui nous ont sortis
des machines de guerre des nouveautés
dans tous les sens je voudrais parler
d'ailleurs dans plusieurs vidéos qui
s'affiche ici ou en dessous dans la
description on a eu un déballage de ce
payx de malades et des fonctionnalités
qui n'existait jusqu'à présent que sur
des caméras très très très haut de gamme
et la thur la nikon qui arrive avec son
z 6 2 la deuxième version du c6 qui est
sorti il ya quelques années déjà
maintenant ça fait deux ans à peu près
le betis 1 je l'avais testé il ya
environ un an et j'en avais conclu que
ça serait pas ma machine principale même
si c'était une très bonne machine et on
va tout de suite enfants c'est une
énorme porte ouverte et répondre à la
question est ce que le z 6-2 rivalise
avec 1 et auxerre 5 ou un sony à 7 est
roi la réponse est à niveau ce payx
carrément bas mais alors vraiment
vraiment vraiment pas mais alors vous
allez me dire mais
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi tu fais le
choix de partir sur du nikon pourquoi tu
fais le choix de partir là dessus si tu
nous dis que niveau spex sa rivalise pas
du tout eh bien c'est ce que je vais
tenter de vous expliquer dans cette
vidéo
et surtout restez bien jusqu'à la fin
parce que c'est un raisonnement qui m'a
pris du temps que j'ai construit sur un
laps de temps assez long pour arriver à
comprendre un petit peu tous les tenants
et les aboutissants du truc donc ça
mérite d'écouter l'intégralité du
discours quand j'ai eu les gens de chez
nikon au téléphone il ya quelques mois
et qui m'ont dit la liste des spex dans
ma tête j'avais quand même envie de
répondre sérieux mais revenons un petit
peu sur le sujet qui nous intéresse pour
savoir si je voulais switcher changer de
caméra ou pas je me suis posé la
question
de quoi est ce que j'ai besoin que ce
soit pour mes vidéos youtube où mes
prestations en tant que vidéaste parce
que le coeur du problème il est bien là
de quoi est ce qu'on a besoin et qu'est
ce qui va nous permettre de faire notre
travail au mieux alors pour le côté
youtube
le z 6,1 me convenait parfaitement je
fais mes vidéos avec depuis hyper
longtemps ça me va très bien donc là
dessus le betis 2 ça peut être que mieux
maintenant pour les prestations que ce
soit du mariage ou de l'événementiel ce
que je fais la plupart du temps parfois
il ya des clips parfois il ya des pubs
mais la plupart du temps c'est de
l'événementiel pour ça j'ai besoin d'un
erreur laisse les réflexes on oublie
c'est trop lourd c'est trop grosse et
dépasser les mirrorless sont meilleures
en vidéo il n'y a pas photo sans mauvais
jeu de mots faut que ce soit simple à
utiliser
léger compact que j'ai deux slots sd
aussi pour avoir du backup au cas où il
m'est arrivé des mésaventures avec ça
donc je vous mets une vidéo en lien pour
vous montrez là quel point c'est
important d'avoir deux slots faut aussi
qu en plus de la vidéo il soit
performant en photo parce que de plus en
plus on me demande de la photo et en
travaillant avec marion a besoin d'avoir
des boîtiers qu'ils soient polyvalents
en photos et en vidéos et enfin j'ai
besoin d'avoir la possibilité
ponctuellement d'avoir du cat de 10 bits
du log et éventuellement du rau et là on
est vraiment sur des prestations
ponctuelles c'est pas sur la globalité
du temps que j'aurai besoin de ces
fonctions là mais si elles y sont c'est
cool maintenant de quoi je n'ai pas
besoin alors clairement la bic a pas
besoin
la plupart du temps je livre mes vidéos
à mes clients en full hd parce que c'est
à destination du web x alors qu'on vient
de très bien
déjà rien qu'en full hd quand je livre
un prores pour avoir le moins de
compression possible les gens font c'est
beaucoup trop gros tu peux d'une
compressé l'avicca pour l'instant j'en
vois pas l'utilité
si c'est pour recadrer j'essaie de
cadres et bien dès le départ ça me
suffit pas besoin de recadrer en 8k fois
ensuite la 4k 120 fps c'est pas
forcément quelque chose dont j'ai besoin
plus le temps passe plus je shoote
meslot mots en 60 fps
parce que au final j'ai pas des actions
hyper rapide à filmer et des gros gros
ralenti à faire au final avec du 60 fps
j'arrive largement à faire le slow mots
que je veux et puis j'essaie de mettre
de moins en moins de saumos aussi dans
mes vidéos parce que je me dis que c'est
un peu la facilité enfin le cadre de 2
10 bits interne
honnêtement j'ai toujours là tomos sur
mon boitier que je filme en interne ou
en externe donc si j'ai une caméra qui
fait du cas de 0,8 en interne mais duke
est de 2 10 bits en externe
ça me pose aucun problème dans la mesure
où j'ai déjà l'atome hausse qui va avec
pour faire ça en externe du coup si je
reprends tout mais point de la liste le
set 6-2 koch absolument toutes les cases
et même s'il n'y a pas d'énorme
nouveautés sur la nouvelle version
en gros on garde tout ce qui avait de
bien dans le set 6 1
on rajoute deux flottes alors un slot sd
et un slot cf express donc ça ça change
pas on a juste à rajouter une carte sd
pour avoir un back up c'est parfait il
ya un nouvel autofocus qui est hyper
performant vraiment le tracking est
vraiment bon on aura d'ailleurs le
tracking sur la vidéo en 4k le tracking
de visage
et ça c'est quand même hyper cool à sa
sortie il fera le maximum de la 4k à 30
fps mais il ya un firmeware qui sortira
au mois de février qui va débloquer la
4k 60 fps en interne
donc là dessus c'est pareil je pourrais
avoir de la 4k oslo mots ça sera déjà un
hub graines par rapport à ce que j'avais
là actuellement
et en plus de ça à force d'utiliser le
set 6 1 je me suis aperçu qu'avec
beaucoup de choses que j'aimais chez
nikon notamment les optiques les focales
fixes sont vraiment hyper intéressante
parce que trop
lumineuse passe que très compact très
légère donc ça fait des rings qui sont
légers quand j'ai le 35 mm j'ai
l'impression d'avoir rien dans les mains
et c'est tellement tellement tellement
agréable je suis vraiment attaché à
l'image et au rang d'une icône l'autre
point que j'aime beaucoup et que je
retrouvais pas sur les autres boîtiers
c'est qu'en photo ça dépote vraiment en
photo ça me donne envie de faire plus de
photos d'ailleurs vous pouvez aller
faire un petit tour sur l'instant il ya
plein de photos prises aux aides cissé
oz 6 2 et ça donne envie de faire de la
photo en fait est quelque chose que
j'avais pas avec mon boitier sony et
puis ça je vous en parlait il ya peu de
temps
il ya la possibilité d'enregistrer en
prores rovia anatomo et ça c'est un
codec vraiment que je kiffe et que
j'aime travailler parce que très très
très flexible je m'en sers pas tous les
quatre matins
mais quand j'ai inclus pas tourné j'ai
pas à rougir de pointer avec mon z6
aimons atomos parce que je sais que je
peux quand même sortir de la 4k en
progrès 0 et ça c'est quand même assez
ouf pour un boîtier de cette taille est
de ce prix et c'est là qu'en fait
certaines personnes n'ont pas compris la
philosophie de nikon c'est que ce
boîtier il ne vient absolument pas
concurrencer 1 et auxerre 5 ou 1 à 7 est
roi parce que déjà il n'est pas du tout
dans la même gamme de prix pour un air 5
on a 2 et 6 rien que ça c'est la moitié
du prix donc forcément on pouvait pas
s'attendre à avoir des spex équivalente
et est ce que vraiment on en avait
besoin
moi personnellement je n'ai pas
l'utilité données auxerre 5 vous donne à
cet étroit pour la plupart des plans que
je fais donc en gros ce récit ce même si
on pouvait lui reprocher quand fait
finalement cette deuxième version
elle est ce qu'aurait dû être la
première puisqu'il manquait vraiment pas
grand chose les deux flottes sd un très
bon autofocus la 4k 60 fps et ça aurait
été pliée là il aurait plié le game
d'entrée de jeu il ya deux ans bon il
sort que maintenant n'empêche qu'il est
vraiment très très bien et surtout il
est abordable par rapport à d'autres
boîtiers maintenant il ya un autre
aspect de la réflexion dont je voudrais
vous parler par rapport à tous ces
boîtiers qui sont sortis c'est vrai que
quand on voit les spex de certains
boîtiers ans se dit ouah quand même il
ya moyen de faire des trucs tu envoies
du bourg mais un air 5 points à 7 et 3
ça reste cher pour un boîtier photo
pourtant moi j'avais quand même envie
d'essayer un petit pot de de muscler mon
jeu essayez de level up
donc je suis parti sur cette réflexion
là quitte à sortir de la thune pour
acheter une caméra qui envoie du lourd
autant que ça soit entre guillemets une
vraie caméra voir une caméra de signer
qu'ils aillent vraiment plus loin que ce
que font actuellement les boîtiers et
c'est là que le seul hic en parallèle
pour level up j'allais commandes et
tenez vous bien une raide komodo donc
elle est pré commander elle sera en plus
de ce set
nikon qui va me servir pour le travail
de tous les jours
la red ça va être bon déjà pas se mentir
pour me faire plaisir parce que parce
que j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir une raide
c'est des caméras qui me font rêver
depuis toujours et aussi pour aller vers
un autre univers celui des caméras
cinéma je trouve que c'est une bonne
porte d'entrée dans les caméras cinéma
chose que j'aie jamais manipulé jusqu'à
présent j'en arrive un peu à un stade où
j'ai la sensation d'avoir fait le tour
un petit peu de ce qu'on peut faire avec
des dés mirrorless avec des boîtiers
hybride et j'ai envie de découvrir un
petit peu ce monde de la caméra de
signer pour ça que j'ai commandé une
raie de komodo parce que je me suis dit
en fait pourquoi aller se limité avec
des boîtiers 1er 5 qui va chauffer qui
va avoir tout un tas de limitation ou un
sony qui va être du sony que je connais
finalement même si je l'étais steak l'a7
est roi c'est une machine de ouf
pourquoi pas aller directement sur un
truc carrément au dessus puisque l'arrêt
de komodo et quand même abordable pour
une raid 1
ça reste quand même cher mais quitte à
mettre de la thune
je me dis que je préfère acheter une
raide komodo qu'un à 7 est roi et
utiliser cette série nikon z qui est
super pour 90 % on va dire de ce que je
fais au quotidien dans mon travail et
pour youtube et à côté utiliser cette
komodo pour de nouveaux projets dont je
vous parlerai très prochainement et un
projet par contre que vous pouvez faire
tout de suite et qui est très simple
c'est celui de mettre le coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste
en dessous de cette vidéo les amis pour
aller voir d'autres vidéos
si vous découvrez la chaîne ou si vous
en avez vous pouvez vous abonner activer
la cloche pour être notifiée tout ça
tout ça et puis moi je vous dis ray
c'était curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
donc je suis comme un gosse à noël la
komodo et commander je l'attends je sais
pas tout à fait quand elle va arriver et
frau là ça va être tellement dément ça
va être tellement dément